Santana is with us in Tennessee I sent
Anna hi thank you for taking my call so
um I have okay we have three businesses
three small businesses and they kind of
go hand in hand with each other we have
a diesel repair shop we have a trucking
company that does over the road trucking
and then we have several rental
properties so we have three different
businesses each one of those businesses
has debt
so there's loans that go along with each
one of them and then my husband and I
have personal debt as well I just
started listening to you in February and
then I just finished the financial piece
just here recently with the hope offer
that y'all are offering my question is
we don't I don't know whether to do a
budget for each business because those
loans are tied to those businesses and
then also we don't we don't have a
steady amount that we pay ourselves I
don't even know if we're supposed to be
paying ourselves but for those personal
debts as well I want very badly to make
a budget and stick to the budget so that
we can get out of debt I don't know how
okay yeah this is great
well the the thing is yeah you know the
thing is you don't have any business
debt a hundred percent of your debt is
signed part for personally so it's as
far as the law is concerned it's all
personal debt you've got it categorized
as a business debt in the way you're
treating it and that's fine but there's
no rule that says that the trucking
couldn't pay off the repair place or
vice versa okay now what I would do is I
take your rental properties and I would
make them a baby step six if you've been
studying our stuff those are just
personal rental properties you have debt
on those I would treat those in baby
step six the other debts how much debt
on the repair shop alive how much
I don't know I just I just started
listening in February and I've been
trying to write down everything I don't
I don't have all the numbers together
okay who runs the shop I do the
bookkeeping but I I don't have a degree
or anything like that my husband wanted
to start the shop he worked on the road
for 13 years yeah
so if you were going to cash how much
would you guess on the shop probably
property in all four hundred thousand
how much of that is property about 250
okay I'd put that 250 with your rental
properties that's real estate dad over
and baby step 6
and so you've got a hundred and fifty
thousand and miscellaneous dad on the
shop roughly roughly okay how much on
there I guess you got a truck dad on the
the over road trucking right yes how
much $67 okay so you got two hundred and
seven thousand dollars roughly and debt
not counting your real estate and not
counting the what you've got at home is
that sound right yeah okay and how much
dad have you got at home not counting
your home he's probably about 25,000
mm-hmm okay all right and you what did
you pay taxes on what was your income on
your tax return last year the income was
actually a loss okay then you how did
you guys pay bills at home if your
businesses were a loss and didn't make a
profit right
I don't know they it came out to be like
four thousand dollars of loss loss what
was your revenue on the businesses
before you paid your expenses how much
income on the between all three classes
on on this shop it was it was about six
hundred thousand gross the trucking
actually was just started here recently
so that was not on last year's tax
return
here's what you need to do you need to
sit down with one of our endorsed local
providers and get the books straight
because you fear the bookkeeper and you
don't know the numbers that's a problem
yes okay so we need to be able to take
each of these situations and say okay
the business even if you combine them
all you look at them as separate
departments we've got the trucking
department we've got the repair shop
department we've got the real estate
department and out of each of those
departments the reason you were showing
a loss of your tax return is the
depreciation on the trucks on the
equipment and on all the real estate
less some of your expenses so you didn't
you really did take some cash home and
I'm gonna guess and say it's under 100
grand though that you tried the traction
it had available to take home but you
really need to get straight on what cash
these businesses are producing real real
cash profit not counting depreciation in
other words okay in other words the
repair shop runs and it pays its bills
what's left okay and then the the
trucking business runs and pays its
bills what's left you may find that you
want to close the trucking business and
run a repair shop you may find that if
it's tough it's not profitable you need
to do that because you need to
concentrate on where the money is coming
from and then make that money then you
can start to run once you've got good a
good set of books and you can start to
determine what is reasonable to try to
take home to pay my bills at home and to
pay pay off begin to pay off that twenty
five thousand but you got two hundred
some thousand to pay on these other two
things there's plenty of money to throw
that direction at the business well
there's a lot of money coming in one of
the nuances and business is you you
don't want to sell everything just to
get out of debt if selling the thing
causes your business to shut down
because that's your source of revenue so
Dave's exactly right you want to get
real numbers so that you know what
you're working with then you want to
work on getting your profit margins up
okay so if you operate it at a loss we
don't want to stay there we want to get
your margins up and you guys are going
to pay yourself a modest salary for a
while until your profit margins are
really rocking and you could pay
yourselves eighty thousand dollars a
year and apply everything we teach in
personal finance and start paying off
the personal debt through that eighty
thousand and then over here in the
business while you're getting your your
profit to increase you
paying yourself a bonus you start paying
off the debt you get the healthy margins
and then you can pay yourself the 80,000
plus a bonus based on the profit and
that's where your gravy can come from as
a business owner related down the road
here's what I want you I want you to be
looking for I want you to be looking for
what in the shop is most profitable
mm-hmm and try to grow that area of
business what has the best margins and
because over the years of coaching
Santana I don't think this is the case
with the numbers you're giving me they
don't I don't believe so but I have run
into people who if if they paid
themselves rent on the on the shop
because you own the building enough to
cover the mortgage or what market rent
was if you were just to be a renter that
the shop actually ends up not being
profitable meaning the only thing that's
profitable is a piece of real estate
I've run into that situation I don't
think that's the numbers in your case
though I think you're running too much
top-line unless you're just miss
managing your expenses to no end
to not have good profit coming to the
bottom on 600k I'm gonna guess and say
you're probably making 100 but minus
depreciation could get you down to a
four thousand other loss because you got
a truck to depreciate that you bought
and well you bought that this year so
that wasn't in there but you get your
point it's revenues coming in so
something's working in there yeah and
you seem to maximize that thing that's
worth as long as you're not you know
bringing in six hundred and spend it cut
expenses or maybe raise your prices a
little bit and get that margin up that's
that's the thing find the sweet spots in
the business and then let's work on
growing that area of the business or
every time that type of business rolls
in the front door then you're smiling
because you know it's got good margin
and and it's a way you can serve your
customers well obviously so that's what
I check on that's what I would do really
gonna be on top of your numbers and
that's gonna help you solve a whole
bunch of these issues you know what your
debts are what your assets are worth
what the income is what the expenses are
what the net cash flow is and then what
the net profit is